is from genomics
thank you the name is biomedical data
science it's too sexy to forget
so i have too many slides um so let me
start with the important one which is an
acknowledge in my collaborators and
anything that is really good and what
i'm going to tell you it's due to them
and the mistakes are due to myself
and this will be a sort of an
advertising type talk and which i don't
typically like but what can you do in 30
minutes so i'll invite you to look at
the paper if you are more interested
so
my goals for today's are to try to
convey that one example in which looking
for a conditional consistent hypothesis
it's a way to unders to get closer to
causal mechanism
and then show you a little bit how the
knuckle framework it's a powerful way of
testing conditional hypothesis and
interests you in the problems of gene
mapping
so i work in a medical school and one of
the big questions that
we have been grappling with in medicine
in and in genomics in the past few years
is the interplay uh between race and
medicine and race and genomics and so
there's papers like this one that
emphasize that um
sometimes in medical education and in
medical practice we give too big of a
role to raise and we treat people
differently because they are of
different races and there is really no
need to do that
there are also papers like this ones
that instead
point attention to the fact that we
don't have enough data on diverse
populations and uh by having this lack
of data we don't treat we don't provide
to everybody the best possible care so
the result always this question of are
we different or are we the same and how
is it that we account for the diversity
that we can clearly see exist between
different human population versus what
are the very common elements that they
share so i'm going to look at this from
one specific point of view which is that
one of uh genus
genome-wide association studies so the
goal of this study is that we have
observations on a trait
y and on a set of
genetic variants
these are
typically quite many
you can think about x's having
one million different variables included
and our goal is to try to identify
which genetic variants encapsulate all
the information that it's in the genome
about the trait
we are particularly interested in coming
up with the selection of positions in
the genome that are relevant for this
trick
let me emphasize that we do not know
what is the mechanism with which y
depends on x
i've already mentioned the dimension
another thing that i want to mention is
that there is a fair amount of
dependence between all of these
different covariates
not all across but locally they have
strong dependence
and let me since we are in this causal
uh
workshop let me spell out clearly what
do we mean with causality in this
context
so what people are interested in is
identifying those genetic variants that
directly impact the phenotype so that if
you have one particular allele at that
position you are going to have a higher
risk of having a certain disease or you
have a higher value or whatever
quantitative trait you are
talking about irrespective of what you
have everywhere in the genome and the
main interest
for this is because this is a way for us
to understand what are the biological
pathway behind these traits of interest
typically we cannot assume that these
causal variants are really genotype so
they might not be in our set of x's and
we can just
and
guess their location by proxy so if we
have association between nearby variants
and the phenotypes we might be able to
detect them
one thing to keep in mind is there a
fair amount of variability in allele
frequencies and linkage disequilibrium
which is with the term we use to
describe
dependencies across the variants across
different human population
the standard way of analyzing this data
is with univariates models so you test a
bunch of hypotheses of independence
between the trait and each of the single
variants and in a very simplistic form
you just use a linear model you actually
use mix effect models but for the sake
of this talk this is okay
and then you do all of these tests and
you try to control a global error rate
like family-wise error rate at the five
percent level
now um
testing all of this univariate
association is not a very fast way to
getting at causal variance because
whenever you have a signal whenever you
have one variant that it's important all
the neighboring variant will also be
associated with the phenotypes it's also
a way that it's kind of
antiquate in the sense you don't use all
of the nice modern machine learning
methods and you have results that are
hard to interpret
um
how about different human populations so
human populations have played a big role
in energy was and the first
uh
type of interest was oh we see that
there is variation across human
populations so we have to be careful
about this because this could induce
confounding and we might find
associations that have nothing to do
with the trade but have to do with the
variability across populations
this
pushed people to look at data from
homogeneous populations so that if you
concentrate only on northern europeans
you are going to see variability that is
associated to variation in phenotype and
not to variation in population
however that makes it difficult to
export the results that you get from
discovery to the rest of the world and
so right now really the main interest in
the genomic field is to get data from
other populations and see where is their
correspondence between the findings that
we make in finland and the findings we
make in other populations so what i want
to talk to you about it's an alternative
approach to do this genome-wide
association studies
that allows us to use
machine learning methods and guarantees
for us false discovery rate control of
the discoveries
but
by using these machine learning methods
output results that are more informative
in terms of causal variant
and
this goes through the
main ingredients of this alternative
approach
are two
one is the idea that instead of testing
independence between phenotypes and
individual genetic clauses we try to
test this conditional hypothesis so we
look we just say that we make a
discovery when we find and snip that has
something to tell us about the phenotype
on top of what the rest of these nibs
have to tell us okay so we want to have
some snip that is uh
we want to reject the hypothesis of
independence between the phenotype and
then snip given the rest of the genome
and then we want to control false
discovery rate rather than family-wise
error rate which is a rather
conservative approach in this text
but in particular today i want to talk
to you about the idea that we have of
trying to make sure that we make
discoveries that are consistent across
populations and so let me uh state
precisely what i mean so imagine that we
have a number e of environments that in
my case are different human populations
but we can do a little be a bit more
general and so let's just talk generally
about environments and we can get
observation from each of these
environments and we have a
outcome y and p explanatory variable x's
this um independ conditional independent
hypothesis for each environment can be
stated as the outcome y e it's
independent from the explanatory
variable xje
given the rest of the explanatory
variables in environment e
and what i mean with consistent
hypothesis
it's
an hypothesis that it's no
if there exists at least one of these
environments where this uh conditional
independence hypothesis is true so if
you make a consistent discovery it means
that you discover a variable x j that
it's not independent
from y given all the other variables in
every single environment
this i want to argue that and i'm not
you know certainly the first one to
argue this that this brings us closer to
the identification of snips that truly
have causal effect if i find a snip that
it's associated to high cholesterol
level in every single human population i
tend to believe that it's
more likely to be causal than one that
has association in some population and
not in others and of course the uh work
of jonas peters peter bulman minhausen
and everybody else has inspired quite a
bit
let me give you a graphical view of um
one
particular way in which this can be true
that it's kind of relevant for
genetics so we have a
four covariate z and kova and with a
certain distribution p z e that depends
on the environment and we're going to
represent the relationship between these
variables with this graphical fashion
the gray nodes are the observed variable
and the white nodes they're not observed
so you can see that the covari well i
don't know how well you can see it let
me tell you the covariate c1 it's called
c1 because it's unobserved so it could
be a confounding factor
there is these two dotted lines here
represent the true mechanistic model
that generates y so y depends on c1 and
x1
now let's see what we might observe in
different environments so in one
environment
it may be that variable x2 is correlated
with variable c1 so when we try to
reconstruct conditional independence we
might discover an association a
conditional dependence between x1 and y
and x2 and y
x2 it's there because x2 car information
on c1 which is really important for
determining y
in another environment instead of having
an association between c1 and x2 i might
have an association between c1 and x3
and in this environment when i go and
try to test conditional associate
independence i'm going to make the
discovery of a conditional dependence
between x 1 and y and x 3 and y and
these discoveries are correct right
because in this environment x3 carried
the information for x2 but now if i look
across environments i can see that this
green arrow which is the one
conditional independence
dependence discovery that i have made
that it's consistent across environments
is the one that corresponds to a true
causal direct association while the red
one doesn't
and we think that this is not a bad
representation of what might be going on
in genetics right remember what i told
you often the causal variable it's not
typed and what you are going to do it's
discover and
and sometimes you make discovery by
proxy and what's happened uh in genetics
is true it's that you actually have this
change of distributions of the
covariates across populations and these
two pictures which i'm sure going to be
pretty cryptic if you are not in
genomics our picture describing you how
there is a very different uh
distribution marginal distribution of
the alleles in different populations
this top picture tells you that looking
at minor allele frequency you can
reconstruct
from which part of the word do you come
even only using 600 markers and this
bottom picture tells you that there is
difference not only in marginal
frequencies but in joint frequencies
okay
now
if we believe in a common causal model
across the environment you can be quite
precise about why looking at this
consistent hypothesis
brings you closer to discus the
discovery of true causal relationship
and we discover a true causal
relationship i mean rejecting these
causal nulls
defined in these terms so if you think
you have an outcome a function that
links your predictors and some noise to
the outcome this is the same function
across environments
you can say that zj it's null if
the outcome the
value of this function f evaluated in
all the covariates with zj or any other
value of zj is the same
but even if you do not believe in this
common causal model
looking at this consistent hypothesis is
interesting if you think of it from the
genetic viewpoint say that you want to
put in place a screening
procedure that says everybody who has
this particular mutation i'm going to
follow up and check if they develop this
disease it's much better even if that
mutation is not really the true causal
one if you can do it for every for
selecting the same mutation for every
human populations right you don't want
to say when somebody comes to the clinic
what are your ancestors and let me find
different tests for you
um
okay this slide is supposed to tell you
that testing this consistent hypothesis
is not a trivial thing
and since we have very little time i'm
not going to uh
be later on that i'm sure you believe me
let me just give you a flavor of how we
go about doing this conditional
independence
testing to do this we use a framework
that is uh has been described as
knockoff framework and let me just give
you a sense of the problem
so to do this conditional hypothesis
testing we don't want to do marginal
tests but we want to analyze the
relationship between a phenotype y and
all of my explanatory variable at the
same time
one way of doing that if i give you the
dimensionality of the problems when i
have a million explanatory variable and
say 200 000 observations is to look at
the lasso and here it's a much smaller
set of simulations where i have
generated
some x 500 explanatory variable and an
outcome from that and then i run the
lasso and what i plot here is the
estimated coefficient the absolute value
of the estimated coefficient with the
lasso
blue dots corresponds to variables that
are not important for the phenotype so
they don't belong to the true model and
the red dots correspond to variable that
do belong to the true model and you can
see that the lasso does a very good job
azuring zeroing out the effect of many
variables that are not important but if
you were to simply look at which
variables have
an estimated coefficient that it's
bigger than zero you have a number of
non-important variables that can be
and the question is where are you going
to
where are you going to threshold what
are you going to consider as important
or not it's not a trivial task
and the idea of knockouts is to in
augment this problem with some dummy
variables and keep track of what happens
to this dummy variable and use them as a
way of measuring when are you including
irrelevant stuff
and um
this is the idea of using gummy
variables is not
new but the way to construct them it's
quite important and just let me give you
a few examples to give you a flavor of
what's going on you could say let me
augment the problem with dummy variables
that have gaussian distribution and the
same mean and the same variant
covariance of my explanatory variable
and let's see what happens and here so i
have a problem where i have now 1000
predictors these are my previous fellows
and these darker blue ones are the
coefficients in the lasso model of the
gaussian dummy variable you can see that
the lasso really understand that these
are dummies because all of the
coefficients are zero but these dark
dots are not a good proxy of the light
blue dots here if i look at what happens
here i don't have if i look at what
happens to this
gaussian dummy i don't have any real
guidance to know what to filter out here
the same way if i do permutation which
is a very natural way of trying to
construct dummy variables and instead if
i follow this magnificent recipe of the
knockoffs i get these dummy variables
that have a distribution that it's
indeed very close to this one
so there's lots of things to talk about
the knockoffs and we have spent quite a
bit of time constructing knockoffs that
are good for genetic data
what i what's new here is that we can
modify this knockoff construction and
the filtering process that comes after
that to test this consistent hypothesis
um it's not a very complicated setup
so let's say that we have three
environments we have our original
variables
outcomes variables then we can construct
knock-offs for each environment so then
our costs have to be constructed so that
they have
the same distribution as the original
variable and they are actually
exchangeable now this distribution
doesn't have to be the same across
environments but in each environment you
construct the appropriate knockoffs and
then from this original variable and
then knockoffs you can get some measure
of importance of each variance
the simplest way is to say
you look at the look let's think of z
this measure of importance to be
exactly what we looked up here so the
absolute value of the
lasso coefficient
to measure the relative importance of a
variable you look at the difference
between this measure on the original
variable and the measure of the
corresponding knockoff so if you have a
w that it's negative it tells you that
then a cup of a variable is more
important than the variable itself so
you probably will tend to believe that
this is not the something that you want
to select
and instead if w is positive and big you
are going to want to select that
variable and what to selection to do or
not it's specified space in the knockoff
filter that we don't have time to go
over with what i want to emphasize here
is that you can extend this construction
to this multiple environment setup you
don't need to assume constant
distribution across the environment
because that will be actually
define the purpose
and then once you have done this
construction of knock-off and knock-off
scores you can actually
um we introduce a new way of doing the
knuckle filters the takes into account
this information that's coming from each
environment and returns for you p values
that can be put in a selection
procedures so that you guarantee fdr
control
now requiring that you have an
association present in every single
environment so that you can reject the
null in every single environment it's
rather strict
you might be interested to say well i
want to see if i have
if i can reject the null in a certain
proportion of environments and that's
what
is known in the literature as partial
conjunction hypothesis
and benjaminian heller described them in
2008 and there has been quite a some uh
advance in terms of what are different
tests that you can use and strategies
and so we can also do this part take
this partial conjunction viewport
let me show you a couple of results of a
genetic simulation and some real
data analysis
because we are strict on time
you'll just believe me that this genetic
simulation has been done with some
reasonable criteria
okay thank you
uh
well anyway so we have generated data
using some standard
way of doing things and constructed a
phenotype so maybe what is interesting
is that we have
um different populations okay so we take
real data from
five different groups
and we generate a phenotype for each of
this group in this case
we are using a constant model okay so
we're saying there is the same real
model that
determines the phenotype for each
population
but what we do is that we select the
snips that are important for this
phenotype so that they have different
allele frequencies across the different
groups
and
to clarify we select the same snip to be
important across population groups but
we don't impose them to have the same
effect so in fact what we're going to do
is that the sign of the effect it's a
coin flip across populations
and uh also the size of the effect it's
randomly sampled and why is that
because this is one way of think of
capturing what we think is going on in
human population we think we are all the
same that if i
could if for me
if in european or in africa
we were able to reproduce the same
genetic pattern it would have the same
effects but in reality what happens we
have some alleles that are present in
europeans and some alleles that are not
and somalia that are present in africans
and some are not so if there is a
mutation that will
really increase my cholesterol level but
this mutation is not present in the
population i belong to i will not be
able to detect it in european but if i
were to introduce this mutation in
european it would have the same effect
another complication is that
even if there is the same biological
pathway going on often there is an
interaction between genetics and
environment and different human
populations are exposed to different
environments so when you go ahead and
try to detect and estimate the causal
effect um in of one mutation in one
population or the other one you might
see a difference so what we're trying to
do here is to capture the idea of
there is the same biological pathways
involved in these phenotypes but they
are maybe perturbed in slightly
different ways in different populations
all the causal variants are unmeasured
so we are in this situation where we
just can detect by proxy and so what do
we describe as a true discovery we're
actually testing the genome blocks by
block
and saying do we have a causal variant
in this block so we might not have typed
it but we can specify
geographically if you want the
localization of a position in the genome
and say it's in this part does this
portion of the genome contain a causal
variant or not
okay so we go through uh
our procedure and let me contrast for
you this uh two different analysis
in this panel that's called separate
analysis we analyze each population
separately
and um
you have lots of powers
for two different these two lines
corresponds to different block size we
don't need to compare across
and then you have a variety
with irritability we indicate different
signal strength so higher readability
means that you have a stronger genetic
signal
now
what's reported here it's causal fdr
and with causal fdr we mean do you make
a false discovery if you make a
discovery that it's not in one of these
blocks that contains the true causal
variant
it might not be totally a false
discovery in the sense if you look at
the patterns of dependency you might
have an association there okay but it's
not an associ but it's an association
that corresponds to my
red arrows here okay i'm trying to
distinguish the red arrows that might be
correct discoveries but they are not
causal discoveries from the green ones
so the causal fdr refers to
is your discovery false or not from the
causal viewpoint and so what you can see
here is that even if our method would
control the fdr in terms of simply
looking at is
conditionally independent or not it does
not control the causal fdr when we do in
the single population analysis when we
combine them and we say actually let's
look for this consistent hypothesis
we achieve this causal fdr control
the lines that you're supposed to look
at are the blue ones the red ones are
other sort of cheap ways of trying to
achieve the same
result and clearly they do not
okay this is real data and the results
are not that exciting if you want
but
it's a uk biobank data so this is a big
biobank that it's mainly composed it's
composed by uh citizens of the united
kingdom so in terms of ancestry they are
mainly british as you can see and then
you have a big contingency of other
europeans but you have some small groups
of other populations so the difference
in sample size means that really in
these studies we have power to detect
deviation from independence
substantially in british only and maybe
a little bit in european in the other
populations we have very little power so
the moment we are going to try to
combine and then say i want to have a
consistent discovery i wanted to be able
to reject the no in all the populations
you are going to run into trouble
but that's how our analysis goes this is
just an example
we are going to test if we have
independence in at least one environment
sorry or at least two environments or at
least three or at least four
these
blocks correspond to the different
resolutions at which we can analyze the
genome and they go from low resolution
at the bottom to high resolution at the
top so what's happening here is we are
reporting the blocks
that have been discovered as
conditionally
not independent from a given phenotype
and you can see that we make
more discoveries at lower resolution and
then when we try to specify exactly
where
the causal variance is increasing the
resolution we get more precise outcomes
you can see that we make more
discoveries this is just one particular
location in the genome
put here for me to illustrate the type
of discoveries we make these are
discoveries that are true in at least
one population when you restrict to at
least two the number of discoveries
diminishes and it diminishes even more
as you increase
so here are the results for two
phenotypes height and platelet count
and these are the various type of
resolutions you can see that if we have
very spec high resolution we don't have
very many discoveries but let me guide
you through this table these are these
multi-environment knockoff filter
discoveries so the one that i want to
argue for you
these are the discoveries that you get
if you pull everybody together and you
analyze every properly every individual
as part of the same populations
and
these are the discoveries that you make
if you say i analyze every population
separately and then look for discoveries
that are uh made in every single one so
you look at the intersection
now there's two numbers here the first
number is the number of discoveries we
make the second sorry the second number
is the number of discoveries we make the
first number is the number of
discoveries that have been
externally validated so maybe you can
just focus on the percentage and what
you can see here is that when you do
use this
multi-environment
approach you make discoveries that are
that have higher chance of being
externally validated than when you say
you do the pulling approach and ignore
these
differences and the pulling approach is
equivalent to really make a discovery
that it's true in one environment at
least
so
enforcing that the discovery has to be
true not just in one environment but in
at least two
increases your chances of being
externally validated and gives you more
discoveries than if you do the
intersection okay now i think we are
definitely out of time
so i thank you for your attention
i hope i convince you that
genetic variation across human
population it's an interesting case
study to think about what does it mean
to a recovery a causal ma to recover a
causal mechanism and how do you leverage
the fact that you have
data from different environment in
different populations to do that
i also want to argue that consistency
across environments is meaningful even
if you do not believe in the same causal
model so
and it's
it can be bringing you to the discovery
of causal variants even if the the way
in which they operate in different
environment is different but in simple
but it also brings you to um
the identification of variables that
might be more useful for you for making
policy or making prediction in a way
that it's
acceptable to your population
the
i didn't go into the details of how you
do this testing but um
i want to emphasize that these tests are
valid without making any parametric
assumption on how y depends on x and
without requiring any consistency of
model across different environments
all right and of course there's many
open challenges and thank you
[Music]
and then